[Musique]
monsieur vous êtes le plus ancien garçon
de café du café de la paix depuis
combien de temps que lula en avant mada
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
bon moment de ma jeunesse avec toute la
clientèle et les personnalités qu'on a
pu côtoyer
j'ai le plaisir de servir souvent et
empoché il était charmant pour nous
toujours pressé qu'un jouet les vignes
du seigneur et est toujours passée
l'arrivée désormais j'ai diminué mais
qui se souvient du grand comédien
dictant boucher le café de la paix
témoin de la belle époque
lieu de rencontre des artistes des
promeneurs des étrangers venus de tous
les pôles le café de la paix reste
aujourd'hui avant tout le rendez-vous
des touristes de la capitale
vous en avez souvent entendu parler
avant mais oui allez nous nous venons
souvent parce que j'ai connu
c'est bien pour
mais ce sont les bruit des
marteaux-piqueurs qui accueille
momentanément nautourisme l'opéra n'est
plus qu'un vaste chantier
derrière ces palissades sous la
direction de la quatrième génération de
la même ligne il faut bien dire le
quartier de la paix dit ignor densité
comme nous l'expliquent l'actuel
directeur j'avais toujours hésité à
fermer le cap de la paix pendant un mois
parce que je pensais que c'était une
espèce d'institutions et je n'avais pas
le droit à tous les gens qui auraient pu
se donner rendez vous aux câpres et de
la fed trouvé porte close
la seule raison pour laquelle le café de
la paix sera permet au mois d'août
cette année c'est en raison des travaux
de l'air à bp étant donné que nos
pratiquement nous être bat orion ou
ouaddou avec une terrasse et dont une
recette de café je ne dirais pas
limonade
là c'est le terme de musique d'environ
60 à 70 % de moins que les années
précédentes
il y à une question il y aurait pu être
résolu
c'est 2
d'un peu la ville de paris imposa aux
entrepreneurs qui font les travaux des
mesures pour diminuer le bruit de ces
travaux donc les inconvénients pour nous
dans les proportions extrêmement
notables comme les autres municipalités
de france l'exigent ça c'est moins grave
si la ratp nous procure une
indemnisation raisonnable le capi de la
paix ont besoin de nouveau le 1er
septembre en attendant les touristes
découvrent les petits bistrots de la
capitale
[Musique]